jusqu'à deux jours et non seulement ça se passe bien,
je sais que les anniversaires partout dans le
shopping, tu vas exploser cette nuit en
pleurant dans une minute qu'est-ce que c'est que nous nous séparons
ouais ce soir ce soir je sais que
tu sais ce que j'ai dit comme je l'ai dit
avant  pourrait être ses pires endroits pour
se séparer ouais eh bien non je veux dire parce que
ouais bel endroit pour se séparer il est très
romantique et très mélancolique pas je veux dire
alors que s'est-il passé que s'est-il passé que s'est-il
passé eh bien mon enfant a évidemment été
enlevé par un énorme con six mois
auparavant tourné  dans une escroquerie massive,
puis faites savoir à tout le monde à quel point
il était un maïs massif cette nuit-là, puis
repartez avec un petit pain, alors j'espère que où
qu'il soit dans le monde, il tient sa pancarte
dans cette pièce avec sa tête dans ses mains
dans la honte  maintenant, il ne le fera pas parce que je suis
spécial, je pense que oui, apparemment,
ce n'est pas vrai mon pote et si
c'est [ __ ] de vrai, il devrait être
gêné pour lui-même parce que si je faisais
quoi à part ma jolie d'accord dans un
programme tellement [ __ ]  ng quoi donc qu'est-ce que c'est un
[ __ ] de crime mais ce n'était pas parce que je
ne lui ai jamais mentionné le mot assez vert
, je pense que la raison pour laquelle il s'est
séparé parce qu'il est blanc pour
lui tout seul parce qu'il est si légal était comme
tu sais je veux dire  il ne supporte pas de partager
la scène avec moi non je veux dire donc il
voulait faire sa petite musique de danse ensemble
alors bonne chance à lui de toute façon et l'avez-
vous vue ce week-end qui lit
comme Foo Fighters ouais tu vas ouais ouais
j'aime bien  comme ils doivent penser qu'il a
fait n'importe quoi il a de la bonne musique j'aime la
vente je les aime tous à droite je
pense qu'ils sont bons je pense qu'ils sont un
bon groupe tu sais je veux dire et je pense
qu'ils ont de bonnes chaussures  et une pétition
eh bien je signe une pétition vous a mis sur un canapé
même si en fait c'est votre jambe vers
vous votre succès aujourd'hui
avons-nous besoin maintenant non je ne dis pas que nous
devons réformer je dis juste que nous n'aurions jamais dû nous
séparer  oh ouais mais ça ressemble
à ça je n'ai pas besoin de le réformer ou
plus que vous ne le savez  d Je tout le monde
vient aux concerts pour jouer des
chansons d'Owaisi Je suis dans un bon moment pour
vendre les concerts les disques marchent bien
donc en le regardant nous n'avons pas besoin de le
réformer ou je n'ai pas besoin de le réformer mais
apparemment je  Je supplie toujours de réformer
l'interdiction et je ne supplie pas Je suis juste
toujours énervé que nous nous séparions en
premier lieu ouais tu sais je veux dire ouais
[ __ ] de bon mec parce que je pense que nous
devrions toujours Vic jamais nous avons bien fait
albums mais je ne suis pas tu sais que je ne me réveille
pas dans l'esprit de la [ __ ] de chambre d'or
même si parce que je ne sais pas je suis
assez content de faire ce que je fais c'est facile d'
être moi tu sais je veux dire il n'y a pas grand
mauvais patron me disant quoi faire
ou petit patron
toi